estar un paso adelante del virus es la
estrategia que propone la o ms para
ganarle la batalla a la pandemia
es muy recomendable que los fabricantes
de vacunas comiencen a planificar con
anticipación ante la probabilidad de
tener que ajustar las vacunas ya
existentes just
no está bien tener que esperar hasta el
final para reaccionar al ring la llegada
de la variante omicron que avanza su
camino por los cinco continentes pone un
aviso de alerta a los sistemas de salud
en todo el mundo pero aún no hay que
perder de vista a la variante delta en
francia uno de los países de europa
donde este linaje ataca con fuerza ya se
prevé el pico de la nueva ola a finales
de enero la quinta ola relacionada con
la variante delta se está extendiendo
rápidamente 50.000 casos nuevos cada día
es muchos tiene un impacto muy notable
en el sistema hospitalario en francia en
este momento una persona ingresa en
cuidados intensivos cada 10 minutos lo
ms instó a los países a concentrar
esfuerzos para avanzar en la vacunación
y así frenar más contagios de esta
variante
recordemos que delta representa
actualmente el 99 por ciento de las
infecciones en todo el mundo según y la
base de datos de todas las secuencias
del genoma mientras se terminan de
comprender los alcances de la variante y
los expertos explican que las
restricciones de viaje pueden frenar
momentáneamente la diseminación de
omicron pero no sólo una solución
definitiva o micro no delta las
autoridades sanitarias se enfatizan que
es importante no entrar en pánico